hier darf man
hier da
nichtrauchen
hier darf man
nicht passieren hier darf man nicht
passieren
hier darf man
nicht telefonieren hier darf man nicht
telefonieren
hier darf man nicht laut sprechen
im kino muss man das handy ausschalten
im auto muss man sich anschnallen im
auto muss man sich anschnallen im bus
muss man ein billet lösen
im bus muss man ein billett lösen
ich muss die steuern bezahlen
[Musik]
ich soll nicht rauchen
du sollst dich gesünder ernähren
er soll öfter sport treiben
soll das medikament nehmen ich soll das
medikament nehmen kannst du mir bitte
helfen kannst du mir bitte helfen
ich kann gut rechnen ich kann gut
er kann nicht gut tanzen
er kann nicht gut tanzen könnt ihr mich
abholen
könnt ihr mich abholen ich will nicht
nach hause gehen
ich will nicht nach hause gehen
[Musik]
anita will schon schlafen
willst du mit mir ins kino gehen willst
du mit mir ins kino gehen
was wollt ihr trinken was wollt ihr
trinken
ich kam nicht
ich kann
schlafen ich kann nicht einschlafen
ich kann nicht einschlafen
ich kann nicht einschlafen weil die
nachbarn laut sind ich kann nicht
einschlafen weil die nachbarn laut sind
die nachbarn sind laut deshalb kann ich
nicht einschlafen
die nachwahl
sind laut deshalb kann ich nicht
einschlafen
ich will arbeiten
ich will als elektriker arbeiten
ich will in der schweiz hauselektrik
erarbeiten
ich will in der schweiz als elektriker
arbeiten
arbeiten wenn ich deutsch spreche ich
will in der schweiz
als elektriker arbeiten wenn ich deutsch
spreche ich will ich will
du willst du willst er sie es will er
sie es will
wir wollen wir wollen ihr wollt ihr
wollt sie wollen sie wollen
ich muss ich muss du musst du musst sie
es muss er sie es muss wir müssen wir
müssen müsst ihr müsst sie müssen sie
wissen ich
ich darf
du darfst du darfst er sie es darf er
sie es darf wir dürfen wir dürfen ihr
dürft ihr dürft
sie dürfen sie dürfen
ich kann ich kann
du kannst du kannst er sie es kann er
sie es kann
wir können wir können ihr könnt ihr
könnt sie können sie können
ich soll ich soll
du sollst du sollst er sie es soll er
sie es soll
wir sollen wir sollen
ihr sollt ihr sollt sie sollen sie
sollen
hat dir das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal habt ihr das
video gefallen abonniere unseren kanal